ich glaube heute wird sie das erste mal
sein dass ich eventuell kurzen müsste in
dem video hallo wir sind auch meine
damen und herren mein name ist luca und
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video von mir und zweitens wollen
wir haben hier eine menge produkte
liegen davon habe eine menge produkte
liegen wir haben wir vorher einen mix up
stehen meine damen und herren neben dem
mixer haben wir eine flasche orangensaft
stehen wir haben hier eine schale mit
zehn gefalteten zahlen sind da drin
die haben wir wahre aufstehen und hier
vorne haben doch zwei fehler stehe die
sind gerade noch lehrer und eltern noch
leben weil das video noch nicht wirklich
angefangen hat meine damen und herren
ihr könnt euch vielleicht schon leid
denkt heute machen werden und zwar alle
legen freude hier haben also wir das
sind jude film ich mal kurz cool gefüllt
wir haben uns gedacht es gibt meistens
musik also irgendwas mit erdbeeren und
brombeeren und orangensaft oder
irgendwie sowas und es gibt die kraft
des movies irgendwie keine ahnung wenn
man das damit 48 und mit gewürzgurken
wasser und sowas aber wir dachten uns
heute dass wir das ganze einfach mal
mischen werden deswegen wti schon haben
wir hier zehn verschiedene produkte
vorbereitet das erste produkt haben sind
glaube ja sehr sehr schöne blau werden
das ist natürlich ein sehr leckeres
produkt vereins musiker haben wir ein
thunfisch naturale ohne öl der jetzt
sogar abgelaufen
also das wird nicht so gut schmecken
daher fordert eine bananen liegen
die ist ganz frisch die haben sogar
schon aufgestellt müssen was davon
gegessen dies auf jeden fall sehr lecker
dann habe ich ihr fahrer allerdings
gewürzgurken und ist nur die machen die
sich nicht so gut wie vorname dann hin
wäre dass es wieder ein sehr leckeres
produkte haben wir vorne ein würzburger
premium ist also ins musikbusiness
ekelhafteste was es gegend gegeben wird
dann haben wir hier eine frische strauch
weintrauben
dann haben wir hier das ist das mittel
scharfer delikatess selbst
ich glaub ich auch nicht so gute musik
macht dann habe ihr vater erdbeeren und
reinen hühnereis kopf also wirklich eine
bunte mischung aus wie klafften und
leckeren sachen wir bereits erkennen
sind diese mit verschiedenen zahlen
beschriftete und die gleichen zahlen
befinden sich auch in dieser schade hier
drin das heißt die jule und ich werde
nun abwechselnd hier auch eine zahl
ziehen und dieses produkt wäre dann auf
unseren jeweiligen teller packen das
heißt gast ist dann quasi mein teller
dass jedes jurist heller und dann machen
wir uns nacheinander unseres musi und
müssen dann trinken beziehungsweise
probieren ich denke ich dass in den
austrinken werden oder allerdings
freunde würde ich sagen wir fangen jetzt
direkt an und jubeln darf als erste ziel
ist schon aufgeregt
also schule da vorne hat die sachen sind
schön durchmischen und jetzt kannst du
dir einen davon rausnehmen
die spannung steigt freunde es ist die
zahl
warum nein ich kann jetzt die
weintrauben auf das ist mein teller als
jula die jetzt als erstes die
weintrauben wie übrigens freunde jude
hat es die weintrauben gezogen meine
damen und herren
aber es ist noch nichts verloren freunde
ich möchte das ganze jetzt auch mal
schön durch und könnte mir einen kleine
zettel
das heißt die spannung steigen uns auf
die drei name ist übrigens das heißt wir
dann nachher kommt jetzt hier auch schön
auf meinem teller freunde das heißt
julie freut sich schon auf den punkt
fischen jule kommt wieder ins geschehen
gelaufen
wir sehen hier vorne werden schade es
sind nur noch diese acht sachen übrig
juli ist er gespannt
schön dass ihm ein kärtchen elsa guck
mal da wird dir wieder schön rum geburt
stellt in dem die jetzt zieh deine karte
wo die spannung steigt die freunde was
du schimmel ist irgendwie da freut sich
schon auf den thunfisch dich freunde
man muss allerdings sagen es ist noch
immer nichts verloren wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie es gibt noch zwei gute sachen
dabei also ich bin der care tätig sich
zukommen
die pflicht gekommen es ist er wieder da
ist
ich bin aber ehrlich gesagt froh dass es
nicht der thunfisch geworden ist weil
ich glaube das ist auch schon entwickelt
hat als grundlage haben uns übrigens
gedacht diesen orangensaft zu nehm ich
weiß ja wie schon gesagt habe kurzes
update mainstädter besteht aus einer
banane eine minderheit kopf und
jugendalter deiner sieht so perfekt aus
bisher nicht ich kenne sie ist jetzt
erst mal schön noch die erste
zieht ein zettelchen freunde und welche
zahl ist es ist das sind so 66 alter
zwar schön dass wir das ist auch keine
teile neu kupfer die habe ich hier oben
angesetzt die 90 da vorne an alter
freunde die variation frage jungen das
ist eine sexuelle 9 jakub es ist eine
sechs das hast du vor einem volk hat
doch schon zwei bringen diese sachen
alter und häufig auf ein bierchen
freundes ist noch immer nicht verlobt
und ich sagte dass ich mal hier als das
einfach diese station indirekt auskommt
bitten oder nein nein
in die kästen sind sollte kommt schon
mit biker deutschen scherbe getreten
juden immer wieder am start
das bringt gar nichts was soll das
bringen
julia hat schön gelöst
das ging bei hewlett ist halt dass die
gewürzgurke sogar richtig gerne ist
deswegen grünen gibt mir alles außer 2
all zeit echt nicht kommen
ich nehme jetzt diese dieses diesen
zettel nämlich heute keine zwei einfach
[Musik]
walter ich wusste dass es so enden also
jule hat die laut werden das heißt nicht
bekommen dementsprechend hier noch die
erdbeeren 10 wären eigentlich ein bürger
sagen das ist eigentlich eine gerechte
verteilung also freude wer wird die
smoothies vorbereitet wir müssen jetzt
ich habe diese vier für diese fünf
produkte und hat diese fünf produkte wie
gesagt die grundlage bildet einen
orangensaft das heißt ich würde sagen
wir stimmen dass er bis jetzt mal
zurecht attacken das da rein und wir
fangen an mit meinem zu die also bis
gleich 2000 jahre später einige jahre
sind vergangen freuen wenn wir haben
sondern sobald in verschiedenen smoothie
inhalte vorbereitet erst mal das von
jude dass ich so aus also wie ein ganz
normaler smoothie und dann kommen wir
hin zu meinen wir haben hier ja da
schmeiß dich doch direkt einen löffel
weg wir haben hier senf banane eine
nudel reis topf werfen und thunfisch und
das kommt jetzt zusammen mit o saft in
den mixer also zunächst einmal hier die
erdwärme ryan dunn den reichsten
bisschen dann die banane der wirt vom
tisch ein bisschen schneller von ihnen
selbst obendrauf heute hier zu behalten
weil der kreis leer
also es ist als ob ich noch das aus dass
ich glaube heute wird so das erste mal
sein dass ich eventuell kurzen müsste
einem video und es geht los
jetzt spielen wir oft wieso mal 80 die
gerade
freunde dieser hier wird es ab dem
ersten sechs in dem comic shop.de die
desktop geben das ist ein ausgewachsener
oversize richtig gemütlich rudi mit
sonne richtig fetten kapuze ich hatte
richtig bock den zu machen wir haben
hier ein stück drin luchse haben
schriftlich von mir geschrieben befindet
tasche holte das erste wasser gerne
selbst gemeinschaft haben geht es hat
sich jetzt vielleicht total bescheuert
an aber es riecht nach einem
vergammelten beat hess die bagel von
mcdonald's nie zu fest wie das nicht
weil ich schon mal mit back 2 auch noch
meine wohnung abnehmen lassen
aber okay meine damen und herren ich
will natürlich ihre man das heißt wir
kippen die ganze früher jetzt mal hier
vorne rein
die den wir haben der sieht gar nicht
mal so beschissen aus zieht auch sie
soll marius museum liegt allerdings auf
kompletter verwesung
ich habe noch immer ein bisschen den
mund ich will das nicht als kompromiss
freunde das riecht todes klappt ist es
schmeckt todes geklappt ich nehme ihnen
besonders kleinen löffel ok kommst du
den soviel dem ich jetzt doch ok man
kann nicht sagen wo nachts schmeckt ich
würde sagen das ganze schmeckt auch sein
also man schmeckt sehr penetrant krass
den senden und in kombination mit dem
fuß ab also schmeckt eigentlich novi sad
von ursache und der thunfisch der ist so
ich bekomme gerade richtige bauchkrämpfe
hier tun sich war auch einfach seit
einem halben jahr abgelaufen oder so
also mein kleiner tun die ich werde dich
jetzt leider wegschütten ich weiß wenn
jetzt leute ankommen sollten von hey das
ist lebensmittelverschwendung nein ist
es nicht dass es rettung der menschheit
was ich hier gerade mache das ding ist
allerdings dass ich meine smoothie
mittlerweile schon ausgezogen
beziehungsweise probiert habe und
gemacht habe und jule muss ihr
gewürzgurken bier braucht die länder
noch vorbereiten also jude macht ihr
ziel gerade ihren smoothie fertig das
heißt er komme zwei trauben rhein hin
wären blaubeeren
sie sind jetzt alle drin was wir dann
noch die würth gruppe ok go wird drin
vielmehr alter mehr als nächstes nun
genau so wieder mehr in den ich
verursacht damit das ganze verdünnt wird
dadurch allerdings erst dann hast du
dich sagen dafür dann versucht videos
aufnehmen weil du hast ja schon die
beste zeit aller zeiten
darin sehen wir gerade mit ihren findet
ihr am werk
du denkst dass du hier auf erdbeeren
drin ist fertig sollte um dem glashaus
gefordert werde damit jetzt schon drauf
machen kann es nicht schön glashaus
liebe und der kinofreunde das glas jetzt
auch falls nicht wird sagen der sieht
auf jeden fall gar nicht mal so
beschissen aus das sieht jetzt
allerdings echt beschissen aus da ist
sie da mit dem man muss sagen was
natürlich ein paar gute zutaten aber mit
dem bier
hmm ich weiß nicht ob das so gut
schmecken wird schlimm
im ernst als wir das erste staffel also
das schmecken ganz bisschen nach bier
und minimal nach gewürzgurke eigentlich
also ich weiß nämlich gerade verarschen
ob das wirklich relativ gut schmeckt
also es riecht auf jeden fall
es riecht nach garten das riecht nach
frisch gemähten rasen
es kribbelt überall es nun die mit
kohlensäure oder soll ich auch noch nie
erlebt das ist jetzt auf jeden fall -
nur die also du wird sagen es schmeckt
gar nicht mal so kranke oder erst
trinken wenn du den restaurants musik
auch so gibt's zu den wichtigsten
aspekte genauso wird zu ihnen austrinken
ja ihr habt ja das ist wahrscheinlich
auch dir drin angestellte durch das
heutige video allerdings auch beenden
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass jude und ich uns hier
gedacht haben hey zum schrank und jetzt
dazu neben euch gefallen hat dass juden
nicht erkannt
die challenge hat allerdings auch mit
guten sachen einsatzbereitschaft 50.000
live das wird dort oder ja fokus sind
erhöhte nochmals stoffe.de also den
hunden gibt es dann noch nicht meine
damen und herren aber wie gesagt am
ersten sechsten kommt ein heftiger
lautet wer wirklich wie gesagt wer hätte
laut die mühe gemacht haben wir
probieren so viele neue sachen hause
auch hier wieder mit dem ausgewaschenen
schwarze stoffe also ist einfach neues
und jetzt kann das werbevideo auch
einmal wieder weg bald jetzt meine damen
und herren würde ich an dieser stelle
wie gesagt dass wir werden jetzt vom
dach drauf eingehen hat die ganze so
fahren
[Musik]